we're on problem 148
148.
what is the tens digit of positive
integer x we wanted the tens digit
tens digit
statement 1 tells us x divided by 100
has a remainder of
30.
well then we know the 10th digit is 3
right because
let's say
30 divided by 100 has a remainder of 30
and its tens digit is three
a hundred thirty divided by a hundred
has a remainder of thirty and its
remainder is three
and i can make an argument that any
number that when you divided by a
hundred that has a remainder of thirty
is ten's digit is going to be three in
fact that number is going to be
three
zero and it's going to have a bunch of
other digits here there there and if you
just divide this by 100 you're going to
be left over with 30. so statement 1 is
sufficient to figure out what the tens
digit of the number is
statement two x divided by so we could
write
x divided by
110
has
has remainder
equal to 30. well there's a little
different case so definitely when 30 is
divided by 110 the remainder is 30
because it goes into it zero times
so the remainder is 30.
and then the tens digit is three
but let's see i'm going to try to find
other numbers when i divided by 110 its
remainder is 30 but it's tends to just
something else
so let's see
140.
if i divide that by 110
i'm left with a remainder of 30 of
of 30.
but its tens digit is what its tenth
digit is four
right i shouldn't draw an arrow here
if i did let's say i go up one more two
hundred and fifty
two hundred fifty you divide it by one
ten it's remainders thirty but its
tension is five
so this statement gives me no
information saying that the remainder is
30 still gives me no information the
tension can be any of these numbers or a
bunch more if i just kept going so
statement one is sufficient to answer
this question
question
149
149
if x y and z are positive integers is x
minus y
odd
in order for this to happen one of these
have to be odd and one has to be even
and you can just think about that if you
sub take the difference or really the
sum of
two numbers the only way that that
difference or sum is going to be odd is
if one is odd and one is even
so let's think about that let's look at
the statements it's going to see if it
gives any information they say that x is
equal to z squared
well that still doesn't give me well it
gives me no information about y and it
gives me actually very little
information about x just yet i mean it
tells me that x is a perfect square but
a perfect square could be odd or even
right it could be 16 it could be 9. 16
is an even perfect square and 9 is is an
odd one so this doesn't give me much
information by itself
let's see what statement two tells us
statement two says that y is equal to
sorry y is equal to
z minus one squared
so this statement by itself is kind of
like statement one it just tells me that
y is a perfect square of some integer
right because z is an integer so z minus
one is integer so this tells me y is a
perfect square and a perfect square
could be even or odd
but if we take both of these together
then something interesting happens for
example if we assume that z is
odd then its square will also be odd
right 3 squared is 9 7 squared is 49. so
if z is odd and x is odd
and then z minus 1 would be even and
then y would be even so they would be
one would be odd one would be even and
you could do the other way you could say
if z is even
x is even and if z is even then z minus
one is odd and y is odd and i can prove
it to you mathematically let's let's
write this with and substitute for z so
x minus y becomes z squared
minus
z
minus one squared
and so this becomes z squared minus z
squared minus two z
plus 1
and that equals
z squared minus z squared
plus 2z
right distribute the negative sign plus
2z
minus 1. the z squares cancel out
and we're left with 2 z minus 1. if we
use both statements x minus y simplifies
to 2z minus 1. they told us that z is a
positive integer
so this
this part of the statement right here
has to be even it's a multiple of 2. so
this is even
and if you subtract 1 from an even
number this whole expression has to be
odd
so both statements together are
sufficient to say that x minus y is odd
next problem this one looks
looks hairy
150.
henry purchased three items during a
sale he received a 20 discount off the
regular price of the most expensive item
and a 10 discount
off the regular price of the other two
what was the total amount was a total
amount of the three discounts greater
than 15 percent of the sum of the
regular price okay so what was the total
amount of the three discounts it was
twenty percent
times
let's call x well let's just call it
item one
twenty percent times item one
plus ten percent
plus ten percent times item two
plus ten percent times items item three
and i'm oh sorry ten percent times item
three and i'm assuming this is the most
expensive let's say the second most i
guess this is third most expensive maybe
they're the same price i don't know and
they're asking whether this this is the
total discount this isn't what he paid
this is the discount item one the
discount on item two i'm not saying what
they actually paid for item two so but
the question is was the total amount of
the three discounts that's this number
greater than
greater than 15 of the sum of the
regular prices so they're saying was
that greater than 15 percent
of i1
plus i2
plus i3 i think we can simplify this
because if we distribute this right hand
side you get .15
times i1 plus 0.15
times i2 plus 0.15 times i
three
and let's see if we
subtract out 0.15 i1 from both sides
you get
point
see 0.2 minus 0.15 is 0.05
i 1. and i want to keep everything
positive so let me subtract these from
the right hand side so i'm going to
attract 0.1 i2 from
so i'll i'm going to subtract these from
both sides of the equation so that's
going to be greater than
0.15 i2 minus 0.1 i2 so that's 0.05
i2
plus and i'll do the same thing for
i3.15.1 so i'm going to subtract 0.1
from 0.15 so
0.05
i3 all i did going from this to this is
i just distributed the 0.15 and i
subtracted and added to simplify a
little bit and actually this is
interesting too because i just have
these .05s everywhere that's a positive
number and i was able to do that because
i just added and subtracted from both
sides but if i multiply or divide by a
positive number then i don't have to
change the inequality and you could say
let's just divide both sides equation by
.05
or the the equivalent is to multiply
both sides by 20 but then we're left
with i1
is greater than
i2 plus i3
and i think this simplification without
having read the statements was worth it
because we went from something very
convoluted in a very convoluted problem
statement to something very simple so
essentially they're asking us was
the price of i1
was the price of item 1 greater than the
price of items 2 plus item three this is
if we can answer this question we can
answer the harder question
so statement number one
the regular price of the most expensive
item was fifty dollars
i1 was equal to fifty dollars
and the regular price of the next most
expensive item was 20 so i2
was equal to 20.
so now the question boils down was 50
greater than 20
plus the third most expensive item
well i don't know depends well actually
this answers our question right
because i was about to say well the
third most expensive item maybe it's
thirty dollars but
by definition we know that it's not
thirty dollars why because it was the
third most expensive item the second
most expensive item is twenty dollars
so this thing has to be less than twenty
dollars if we are to consider it the
third most expensive item so if this
thing is less than twenty dollars then
the right hand side of the equation is
definitely it's going to actually be
less than 40 so this is definitely going
to be less than 50 so this is going to
be true so it turns out that statement 1
by itself is sufficient because you just
have to realize that i 3 has to be less
than 20 if i 2 is equal to 20.
statement two
the regular price of the least expensive
item was fifteen dollars
so let's see that statement by itself we
get i1
is greater than i2 plus 15 where this is
the least expensive item
so just looking at this we know this is
going to be 15 this is going to be more
than 15.
yeah this is hard you can't say anything
about this because maybe i1 is
maybe i1 is
17 and is 17 greater than maybe i2 is 16
plus 15 and in this case it would not be
the case or maybe i1 is 170
and i2 is 16 plus 15 in which case it
would be the case so statement 2 by
itself isn't sufficient
so the answer to this is a statement one
alone is sufficient to answer this
question see you in the next video